Hold your breath.
The silence.
It's peaceful.
But you think that's weird.
No.
Not at all.
I thought that you
just wanted to be friends.
I don't think we can
ever be just friends.
The only feeling
you are in fact capable
of engendering, my lord,
-is that of discontent.
-Do not move.
-Do you not tell me what--
-Stand still, damn it!
-No, do not! Leave it!
-It is only a bee. Ow!
-Are you hurt?
-What?
Can you breathe?
It is only a sting,
of course.
Are you certain?
-My lord?
-No, no.
Do not…
-My lord?
-Do not…
I am unharmed.
It was just… a bee.
Go ahead.
I'll be right there.
Hi. Was I drooling?
Sorry.
How'd it go? Did you
make it down there in time?
Yeah.
You stayed.
Yeah, I just wanted
to make sure…
you were okay.
Are you happy here?
Yes.
Good.
Wille!
Fuck! Get down.
-Wille!
-I don't wanna talk to him.
-Down! You're glowing.
-Wille!
Wille!
He's probably making out
with someone.
Making out?
Did he leave with someone?
Did he leave with Felice?
-Quiet.
-But we were a group.
Wille!
-Wille.
-Don't do that.
-Wille!
I said, be quiet!
Wait. Wait, no, no!
I cannot just be another
one of your conquests.
Is that what
you think of me?
It's what everyone
thinks of you.
You wanna know the truth?
You are the only girl
who doesn't fall at my feet…
and it is driving me crazy.
It's one of the things…
I like about you.
You're sweet…
but you're not afraid
to call me out on things.
And here I was
thinking I was just
your brother's
annoying best friend.
Well, yeah.
There's that too.
I bet you really miss
your mum, huh?
Yeah, every day.
But, you know, it's…
it's been so long now
that, like…
Okay, it's like this.
I'll be doing my homework
or I will be washing dishes
or something,
and I'm thinking
about my family,
and I forget
that there was a time
where it wasn't just
my dad and my sisters.
And it… it only happens for,
like, a quarter of a second,
but… I feel really,
really guilty about it.
I've never told anyone
that before.
I mean, I get it.
Makes sense to me.
I don't actually
hate my dad,
I didn't mean it like that.
At least he's not, you know…
Dead.
Sorry.
That's okay.
It's actually really nice
having someone
to talk to about this stuff.
You're a good listener.
Yeah?
Why, thank you.
You are too.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
That… that was amazing.
That was nothing.
No, it was above and beyond.
You made me look great
out here.
Well, it's not
a hard thing to do.
Shall we go?
Oh! Thank you for the meal.
-It was incroyable.
-You're welcome.
And may I just say,
you have an exquisite taste
-in lingerie.
-I have what?
-You do.
-He really does. Yeah.
-Bonsoir. Au revoir!
-Thank you again.
No, I'll see you la…
I'll see you later.
Emily…
I have to say that
you did a good job today.
Look, Silvie, I want us
to win, together,
and maybe some things
get lost in translation,
but just… just know
that I'm finding my way.
We're going for drinks.
You can join us
if you want, but…
I think you have
better things to do.
He lives downstairs.
I don't wanna make it
complicated.
Oh, sometimes
the best relationships
are complicated.
Did you forget something?
I did.
Good night.